[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Gerade jetzt im Sommer habe ich wirklich
immer Lust auf etwas Leichtes.
Also gibt es heute einen sommerlichen Nudelsalat.
Den könnt ihr warm oder auch kalt essen,
könnt ihn super vorbereiten.
Es kann auch eine tolle Grillbeilage sein
oder eben an einem warmen Sommertag
eine schöne Hauptspeise.
Ich nehme dafür heute Vollkornnudeln.
Mal gucken, ob es dem Murat auch schmeckt.
Mir schmeckt es sehr, sehr gut.
Und vor allem nehme ich heute einfach ein paar Zutaten
auch gleich noch aus dem Garten.
Den Rucola habe ich noch nicht hier.
Ich nehme noch ein bisschen Babyspinat dazu.
Und das Ganze wird wirklich superleicht!
Ich nehme dafür 60 Gramm Pinienkerne,
eine rote Zwiebel,
30 Gramm Olivenöl,
400 Gramm Cocktailtomaten,
200 Gramm Vollkornnudeln.
Da habe ich jetzt die Farfalle.
Hier habe ich noch 100 Gramm Babyspinat.
Rucola hole ich gleich im Garten.
Getrocknete Tomaten,
etwas Balsamico-Essig,
Salz und Pfeffer
und Babymozzarella.
Ich nehme jetzt zuallererst die Pinienkerne.
Die kann ich nämlich in einer beschichteten Pfanne
schon mal rösten.
Oh, da sind so zwei, die gefallen mir nicht so gut.
Die nehme ich raus.
Die röste ich kurz, bis sie schön Farbe bekommen haben,
und kann ich der Zwischenzeit schon mal die rote Zwiebel
schälen und in Halbringe schneiden.
Eigentlich wollte ich zwei nehmen,
aber die ist echt groß.
Deswegen nehme ich jetzt nur eine.
[Musik]
Und die hier einfach
so ein bisschen durchschwenken ab und zu.
Dann kann ich hier auch schon mal die Tomaten halbieren.
[Musik]
So.
Die sind jetzt perfekt!
Die nehme ich jetzt kurz raus,
die dürfen abkühlen.
Und in der gleichen Pfanne
– jetzt kann ich sie ein bisschen höher wieder schalten.
In der gleichen Pfanne nehme ich jetzt das Olivenöl.
Da habe ich jetzt einfach das Öl genommen
von den getrockneten Tomaten.
Da ist ja wirklich schon megaviel Geschmack drin.
Deswegen brutzelt es auch ein bisschen,
weil da ist ja immer ein bisschen Flüssigkeit drin.
Ist aber nicht schlimm.
Da kommen jetzt die Zwiebeln dazu.
Die brate ich kurz ein bisschen glasig.
Da hat man dann auch einfach
direkt den perfekten Geschmack drin
aus den Tomaten.
Die habe ich übrigens auch schon fein geschnitten.
Die gibt es auch schon geschnitten,
aber ich habe sie jetzt selber ganz kurz geschnitten.
Was ich hier jetzt noch machen kann,
ist das Nudelwasser.
Das habe ich jetzt auch schon gekocht.
Da kommt jetzt Salz rein.
Und die Nudeln kann ich jetzt schön al dente abkochen,
also wie auf der Packungsbeschreibung.
Zehn Minuten brauchen die jetzt bei mir.
Und weißt du was?
Ich stelle jetzt hier den Herd auf mittelhohe Hitze
und wir gehen kurz zusammen Rucola holen. Okay?
Ich nehme was mit. Ich nehme was mit.
Eine Schüssel.
Der Rucola sieht noch ein bisschen traurig aus.
Aber ist nicht schlimm.
Ich nehme einfach noch ein bisschen Sauerampfer dazu.
[Musik]
Okay.
Die Zwiebeln sind jetzt auch so weit.
Rucola und der Salat sind jetzt auch gewaschen.
Hier gebe ich jetzt noch ganz kurz die Tomaten dazu.
Einfach nur kurz mitschwenken bei hoher Hitze.
Die sollen jetzt nicht weich werden,
sondern einfach nur
ein schönes intensives Aroma bekommen.
Die Nudeln brauchen noch knapp zwei Minuten.
Ich kann jetzt hier auch schon Salz und Pfeffer dazu geben.
Jetzt kurz mit dem Essig ablöschen.
Da habe ich jetzt einfach weißen Balsamico.
Ihr könnt aber auch einen anderen hellen Essig nehmen.
Aber der passt schon ganz gut zu dem mediterranen Gericht.
Und jetzt nehme ich es auch schon aus der Pfanne raus.
Jetzt kommen die Tomaten samt Öl und Essig hier rein.
Kurz die Nudeln abgießen.
Wundert euch jetzt nicht über die Menge.
Denn ich habe die ganze Packung Nudeln gekocht.
Aber ich nehme nur die 200 Gramm
für mein Gericht.
So.
Ich glaube, ich nehme doch 250 Gramm,
die Hälfte der Packung.
Das kommt jetzt hier direkt noch mit rein.
So kleben die Nudeln nicht zusammen,
weil ich ja jetzt hier Öl drin habe, den Essig noch drin habe.
Das Ganze kann jetzt kurz durchziehen.
Aber jetzt lasse ich...
Ich gebe noch die getrockneten Tomaten mit rein.
Die sind auch immer so schön würzig.
Aber jetzt lasse ich den Salat abkühlen.
Denn ich möchte jetzt nicht,
dass der Spinat und der Salat zerfällt.
Und auch der Mozzarella soll ja nicht schmelzen.
Also jetzt kurz abkühlen lassen.
Und dann muss ich eigentlich
nur noch die Zutaten untermischen.
Zeit zum Aufräumen.
Jetzt ist der Nudelsalat schön abgekühlt.
Und jetzt gebe ich hier einfach noch den Blattsalat darauf,
das heißt einmal hier Babyspinat.
Den habe ich jetzt gerade noch mal gewaschen
und tropfnass gelassen.
Denn ansonsten trocknet der so schnell an der Luft.
Und den würde ich dann wirklich so
kurz vor dem Verzehr, glaube ich, schon unterheben,
dass er einfach nicht so zusammenfällt.
Dadurch schmeckt er eben auch frischer.
Okay, der ist noch sehr tropfnass.
Aber nicht schlimm.
Dann noch ein bisschen was von meinem Salat hier
vom Garten.
So einen ganzen Unkrautgarten mal hier rein.
Aber ich muss echt sagen,
ich liebe mein Salat-Hochbeet.
Denn du gehst raus mit so einer Schüssel,
mit einer leeren Schüssel,
und kommst rein mit einer richtig vollen,
bunt gemischten Salatschüssel.
So wie diese Salattüten, die man kaufen kann,
kann ich mir einfach draußen auf dem Hochbeet machen.
Also echt cool!
Wir lieben es!
So. Das reicht schon.
Ja, und, wenn es nicht unbedingt nur pflanzlich,
vegan sein muss, dann gerne auch etwas Mozzarella.
Da nehme ich jetzt den Babymozzarella.
Und dann nur noch untermischen.
Das ist mal ein Sommer-Nudelsalat!
Also Nudelsalat ist ja oftmals sehr schwer
und sehr, sehr sättigend,
weil viele ihn auch mit Mayonnaise machen.
Das ist jetzt eine leichte Version für den Sommer.
Könnt ihr gerne mal ausprobieren!
Bei uns gibt es den jetzt gleich zum Abendessen.
Und das Rezept gibt es auf sallys-blog.de
oder ganz einfach in meiner kostenlosen App.
Da könnt ihr euch auch so wie auf dem Blog
die Rezepte hoch- und runterrechnen,
könnt sie euch speichern,
eine Einkaufsliste erstellen
und an euren Mann, Freund oder an eure Frau schicken.
Und dann habt ihr eben alles im Überblick.
Viel Spaß beim Nachmachen!
Und bis zum nächsten Mal!
Tschüss!
[Musik]